hi my name is Keisha I'm studying
physics at something grandma and I was
just wondering whether what a black hole
is and how do we know they exist hi Kish
hey a black hole is an object that has
so much mass and so much gravitational
force that things cannot escape from it
not even light can be radiated from it
so this is a very very concentrated mass
and you ask how would we know that we'd
found one because if you looked at it
you wouldn't see any light coming out so
what we actually see is the light that
comes from materials that are falling
into black holes and the way they become
very hot as they get compressed on the
way in and so we see x-rays and radio
waves and sometimes we even see Jets of
material that are being ejected instead
of falling all the way in so we see
these very active objects and we say oh
they must be black holes but how do we
know that they're really black holes we
have to also determine their size if a
object of a given mass is small enough
then it can't possibly hold itself up
under its own gravitational force and it
must become a black hole so we've
measured some of these we know how big
they are and we're very sure that there
are black holes we've also measured in a
few cases that we can see things
orbiting around a black hole in the
middle of every galaxy seems to be a
black hole of a mass of millions to
billions of times the mass of a single
star so how would we know that we see
that things orbit around them and that
we can measure the mass of the central
object by the way that the orbits go so
we see this in the center of our own
galaxy black holes are much more common
than people imagine they would be many
generations ago when they were first
imagined in fact hundreds of years ago
people ask the question about could
black holes exist but they didn't call
him by that name yet just thinking about
and the speed of light and gravitational
force that could be calculated even from
Newton's laws of gravitation hundreds of
years ago